and we see the riders come up here round
about half-past two is the estimated
arrival but it could change could be a
little bit earlier could be little bit
later
if i'm not mistaken like writing a
report and set off two minutes later
yeah
the biggest crowds we have Jackson the
winos and Stefan
simon yates the youngster from
manchester the world boys race champion
on the team of great britain looks as
though he says set to take his first
ever tour in stage win slamming into
bear pen looks behind these couple depth
Simon Yates has got it simon yates takes
the win wow look at that but i am second
place across the line for thee I aunty
let him buy at martin l major third
place on classification but know about
that for a win team great britain simon
yates two wins on the Tour de l'avenir
this year and the word point race
champion conquers hate or and takes the
victory at the trouble decline on
today's stage of the Tour of Britain
consolation of the top three Simon yet
Martin elegant and David Lopes the first
three riders across the line well that
Devon let you come on continue to
cheerlead right as long as they coming
what a fabulous finished here are the
top of hate or Simon games the young
rider represented great britain direct
sprint leader's jersey uncorking the
jungle champagne if it's anything like
the stage finish yesterday you're going
to get a little damp in the front row as
angled mother XO celebrates in the
traditional manner by spraying the yodel
champagne
so you're going to express their angle
Madrazo of team Bobby Starr
I can
get it
all day
that magnificent trophy made up of the
bicycle chain links to pics in the
outliner got the island of Britain the
home of course for ten years of the tour
of britain cycle race and this is your
leader the IG gold jersey on the
shoulders of sir bradley wiggins of sky
procycling when the car i'll see you
soon